wem gehört die zukunft
nur einer kann die weltmacht nummer 1 1
in china oder amerika
welches politische system ist stärker
die diktatur oder die demokratie es ist
ein duell der wertesysteme dass unser
aller leben bestimmt
[Musik]
die kommunistische partei ist von der
eigenen überlegenheit
überzeugt
präsident biden sieht die usa als
verteidiger der freiheit und der
menschenrechte
china rüstet auf will militärisch und
wirtschaftlich gleichziehen der einstige
partner amerika ist jetzt der große
rivale
die usa wollen ihre wirtschaftliche
vormachtstellung um jeden preis erhalten
ford albans küsten demonstrieren sie
ihre militärische stärke droht der welt
ein neuer krieg
china badet sein volk im nationalismus
präsident ski führt das land mit
eiserner hand der widerspricht wird zum
schweigen gebracht
[Musik]
monatelang hat er die hymne chlorid
ahornbaum nicht mehr gespielt
casey war floh vor chinas angriff auf
seine stadt auf seine freiheit nach
taiwan
er hat damals diesen käfig durch
hongkongs straßen gezogen seine
befürchtungen sind bittere realität
geworden
ich habe hongkong das verlassen hongkong
hat mich verlassen die stadt die ich
liebte lebt in meiner erinnerung fort um
eine unabhängige stimme zu bleiben
musste ich gehen
es war ein aufstand der bürger vor allem
getragen von hongkongs jugend gegen die
alte garde chinas
für ein selbstbestimmtes leben gegen das
sozialistische diktat die freie welt war
begeistert aber sie ging schnell zur
politischen tagesordnung über als die
verhaftungswellen hongkongs freiheit
beerdigte
[Musik]
[Applaus]
seine kunstobjekte konnte er aus
hongkong retten sein studio ist ein ort
der erinnerung und der ermahnung für
seine neue heimat taiwan
alle modernen gesellschaften im westen
sollten sich die geschichte von hongkong
genau ansehen denn
was ist das kann jeder stadt auf der
ganzen welt
scheint der rote riese
sein hunger ist noch nicht gestellt
taiwan als nächstes opfer
casey wong fürchtet chinas weg macht
streben er sieht sich als künstler der
warnen will vor einer düsteren zukunft
diese arbeit zeigt wie grausam und
brutal die folgen einer
wiedervereinigung wären
nach der vereinigung enden die menschen
aus taiwan hier ist eine
furchteinflößende vorstellung ist
taiwan ist die demokratische antwort auf
chinas diktatur nur circa 160 kilometer
ist die insel vom festland entfernt
23 millionen menschen leben hier
1949 die taiwan seinen eigenen weg sein
freies politisches system ist chinas
führung ein dorn im auge eine
provokation
denn es widerlegt pekings propaganda
dass die demokratie nichts für chinesen
sei
[Musik]
die kommunistische partei chinas hat
angst vor intellektuellen vor jeglicher
opposition sie sie kritisiert sie
versuchen alles um kritiker zu verfolgen
zu bestrafen und sie seelisch zu folgen
casey vonn ist ein politischer künstler
im militärmuseum taiwans holt er sich
für sein neuestes projekt inspiration
der chinesische traum von der
vereinigung ist ein gefährlicher traum
wohl mehr ein alptraum weil er krieg
bedeuten könnte
diesen albtraum will wann künstlerisch
verarbeiten
wer in china als präsident historische
größe erlangen will muss geschichte
schreiben der große vorsitzende mao
schuf die volksrepublik china
er schreckte vor brutalität nicht zurück
sich millionen menschen starben während
der kulturrevolution
der heutige präsident will wie eine
historische figur werden auch er
krempelt das land will die macht die
mauer auf lebenszeit
bisher ist dessen größe unerreicht
wenn ich hasse mause er hat für uns um
die herrschaft gekämpft nur deswegen
haben wir jetzt ein so gutes leben
der chinesische traum bedeutet zur
wiederbelebung der nation muss jeder
seinen teil beitragen selbst als kleines
parteimitglied muss ich mein bestes
geben
maus denkmal befindet sich in changsha
hier sind wir unterwegs um einen mann
zutreffen der chinas system infrage
stellt
dafür einen bitteren preis zahlt er saß
monatelang im gefängnis wird rund um die
uhr von der polizei überwacht
anwalt hier young ist ein mutiger mann
sein gegner ist wichtig sie in ping
unterdrückt wie einst mai jeden
widerspruch
meine größte angst ist dass wir wieder
eine art kulturrevolution erleben wir
dachten dass er unmöglich dass sich
unser land bereits geöffnet hätte die
gesellschaft und die menschen viel
weitere wären wir konnten uns nicht
vorstellen dass wir zurückkehren in
diese dunkle zeit der kulturrevolution
aber die wahrheit ist die haben die
kontrolle fähigkeit der kommunistischen
partei unterschätzt und wir haben die
feigheit unseres volkes unterschätzt
auch wenn wir die kameras nicht sehen
china beobachtet jeden unserer schritte
wir wollen diese überwachung inszenieren
um deutlich zu machen dass anwalt vier
young viel riskiert mit uns zu reden
er war menschenrechtsanwalt nahm die
grundrechte ernst doch china ist kein
rechtsstaat
2015 wurde er festgenommen er erzählt
uns wie sie ihn stundenlang mit
hängendem beinen auf einem hohen stuhl
sitzen ließen bis er seine
angeschwollenen glieder vor schmerzen
kaum noch spürte
ich bin anders als andere ich werde
immer 100% widerstand leisten ich sagte
lass uns prudel aber wenn dann vor der
überwachungskamera zu dritt haben sie
mich immer wieder in den toten winkel
gezerrt und ich habe mich immer wieder
in die mitte des raumes zurückgekämpft
damit die kamera und sehe ich dachte
mehr falls sie nämlich methoden bin dann
müssen sie sich wenigstens vor der
internationalen gemeinschaft
rechtfertigen
nach fast zwei jahren muss im
gerichtssaal eine erzwungene
falschaussage abgeben er sagt was der
richter hören will ein eingeübtes
geständnis wie bei schauprozessen üblich
alle hinsetzen bitte bis auf den
angeklagten
[Applaus]
angeklagter young akzeptierst du das
urteil
ich akzeptiere das urteil
gleichzeitig möchte ich mich beim
gericht bedanken sie haben mich nicht
gefoltert sie haben mich nicht zu einer
aussage gezwungen als ich von folter
sprach habe ich die allgemeinheit in die
irre geführt für diese falsche aussage
entschuldige ich mich
wegen ihrer einsicht bekommen sie
strafmilderung
sie werden von dem vorwurf entlastet
umsturz gegen den starts angestiftet zu
haben
sein mandat als anwalt hat er verloren
nicht aber seine stimme sein schicksal
zeigt wie china mit solchen
schauprozessen den eigenen landsleuten
aber auch der internationalen
gemeinschaft
rechtsstaatlichkeit vortäuscht er
spricht für die die aus angst schweigen
oder weggesperrt sind wie die video
bloggerin tante sie wurde festgenommen
verurteilt weil sie hin schaute ihr
verbrechen sie stellte online wie china
ingo hahn mit dem ausbruch der pandemie
umging sie zeigte das leid der menschen
in der stadt
darüber will die kommunistische partei
nicht sprechen
es ist unmöglich für mich aufzuhören
denn das verbrechen in diesem land hört
nie auf
wenn ich sehe dass der staat die
menschen immer mehr belegt und es ein
verbrechen ist sich für die menschen
einzusetzen und über ihr leid zu
berichten dann werde ich immer
weitermachen
verurteilt zu vier jahren haft denn sie
hat nichts zurückgenommen im gegenteil
mit einem hungerstreik protestiert sie
gegen das urteil
ihre anwälte trauen sich nicht mehr mit
den internationalen medien zu sprechen
die young aber duckt sich nicht weg
[Musik]
als challenger nach
branche ein tabu
sie war die andere stimme während der
pandemie vor allem im buch als zig
millionen tiere behandelt wurden co
die partei will das gesicht wahren sie
wollen nicht dass die welt die wahrheit
über man erfährt
menschen wie john chan aber haben alle
die wahren zustände berichtet
damit hat sie die rote linie der
kommunistischen partei überschritten
also haben sie sie eingesperrt
chinas staatsführung reicht es nicht
mehr ihn nur zu beobachten er wurde
wieder festgenommen weil er auch nach
unserem interview für die rechte von
menschen wie sand angekämpft hat
[Musik]
die nächste generation wird in
begeisterung trainiert die partei ist so
stark wie noch nie
[Musik]
präsident schien nutzt die olympischen
winterspiele
um der welt eine perfekt funktionierende
nation vorzuführen
[Musik]
die staatsmacht inszeniert im kampf
gegen das corona virus den triumph
seines autoritären systems
[Musik]
china rüstet sich für das duell mit dem
rivalen usa um die vorherrschaft im 21
jahrhundert
diese generation junger chinesen soll in
amerika den gegner sehen nicht mehr den
partner
[Musik]
es ist ein lied über verbotene liebe
englisch hat sie auf der internationalen
schule gelernt
[Musik]
wir treffen chieming in peking ihr traum
war einmal in den usa zu studieren doch
den hat sie beerdigt sie hat sich nun
für eine schule in china entschieden den
usa uns traut sie
[Musik]
für mich als chemie sind ist es wichtig
dazu zu gehören das macht mich glücklich
wenn ich hier bleibe fühle ich mich
geborgen
[Musik]
familie liebe und in der vierzehnten
etage in einem luxusappartement in
peking
der verkauf von schnaps aus ihrer heimat
mutai hat mutter lied gemacht
[Musik]
sie ist 38 jahre alt eine moderne
chinesische frau geschieden
alleinerziehend als sie vor mehr als
zehn jahren ihre heimat mauerteil
verließ hatte sie nicht einmal genug
milch pulver um ihre tochter zu füttern
die armut trieb sie an heute hat sie
keine geldsorgen mehr sie sind stolz auf
chinas neue stärke durch die staatliche
propaganda hören sie vom scheitern der
demokratie in amerika und dass viele
chinesen dort hass erleben
während der pandemie habe ich erfahren
dass es in amerika rassismus gegen
bestimmte ethnische gruppen gilt
menschen wie wir angefeindet worden
damals konnte ich noch nicht genau
einschätzen wie gefährlich das ist für
mich als chinesen und mutter aber ist es
wichtig dass meine tochter sicher ist
haben sie angst dass ihre tochter opfer
von rassismus gegen asiaten wird
ja genau das meine ich
bis vor kurzem lernte chieming noch an
einer internationalen schule
aber im heutigen china passt das nicht
mehr zum größer werdenden nationalstolz
die kommunistische partei will
kontrollieren was die kinder lernen und
denken
liter hohe unterstützt das denn so
sichert sie die zukunft ihrer kinder
[Musik]
ich zweifle nicht an meine entscheidung
ich halte sie für richtig sie wird auch
englisch in einer öffentlichen schule
richtig lernen denn die haben jetzt auch
einen sehr guten unterricht
chinas elite spürt den neuen kurs der
partei jeden tag kapselt sich das land
ein wenig mehr abwehr englisch lernt
jenseits der staatlichen institutionen
folgt nicht dem nationalen leidet das
weiß familie lee und zahlt für ihren
gehorsam einen hohen preis die kinder
gehen zurück zu den großeltern aufs land
nach mauth um dort eine chinesische
ausbildung zu bekommen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
casey war mist vor dem chinesischen nazi
alles muss nach taiwan geflohen wir
treffen ihn in der hauptstadt im
ältesten tempel seine kunst hat ihn
international bekannt gemacht er ist
einer der wenigen der sich nicht vor
chinas macht verbeugt
deshalb will peking ihn zum schweigen
bringen doch er wird weiter eine stimme
der freiheit sein
[Musik]
dies entschied die entscheidende lehre
von buddha laut ist loslassen
vielleicht sollte ich hongkong loslassen
aber ich kann das einfach nicht
[Musik]
loslassen das wäre wie aufgeben
der tempel gibt ihm kraft und liefert
ihm das motiv für seine nächste arbeit
der chinesische drache guangdong das
symbol für stärke und kampfeswille in
seinem kunstwerk wird sich der drache
befreien müssen um taiwan zu beschützen
die drachen haben sie nichte entführt er
wird uns aber wieder einmal mit seiner
kraft sehnen und uns die freiheit und
die demokratie zu bringen darauf hoffe
ich und dafür bitte ich
casey war fühlt sich auch wie ein
patriot wie familie beide sind chinesen
doch ihre wünsche und hoffnungen könnten
unterschiedlicher nicht sein der drache
kann nur einem dienen
was dem russen seien wodka ist den
chinesen sein motto
die gigantische schnapsflasche ist das
wahrzeichen der region aus der familie
liegt
wie zu hohe besucht ihre kinder und ihre
schnapsbrennerei
die hat sie reich gemacht
nun ist sie zigfacher millionär in
auf chinas nationalgetränk und irland
ist sie stolz
ich als eine normale bürgerin chinas
muss zuerst den staat lieben und ihm
dienen
wer als gute chinesen kümmern uns um
unsere familie und um unser geschäft
das ist das beste was ein
verantwortungsvoller unternehmer machen
kann
chieming will auch eine gute chinesen
seien an ihr altes leben erinnert nur
noch die uniform der internationalen
schule peking
die jetzige ist aus grobem stoff
so wieder unterricht auf der staatlichen
schule
habt ihr hieß gedanken auch als
unterricht
im fach politik da gibt es ein kapitel
über ihre sicher
manchmal schaut sie sich die bilder von
ihren alten klassenkameraden an
einige werden nächstes jahr in amerika
studieren
ihre erinnerung an damals ein video von
auftritten der schulband die kult musik
aus der freien welt spielt
[Musik]
mehr als 2000 kilometer entfernt in
peking verwandelt sich liegen sie in
jessica sie ist eine drag-queen und
kämpft um akzeptanz
ich bin gerne eine drag-queen es lässt
muss mein anderes ich finde
männerkleidung finde ich langweilig ich
bin eigentlich eine stille person
aber nachdem ich mich geschminkt habe
fühle ich mich nicht verwandelt
ich bin ein anderer
dieses gefühl ist befriedigend
[Musik]
jessica gehört zu einer schillernden
szene die für das china von heute zu
bunt ist ihr lebensmodell passt nicht zu
dem bild des gehorsamen bürgers auch
jessica ist patriotisch nur eben anders
[Musik]
geld verdient sie als influenza eine
nische in der sie die partei noch sein
lässt hier gibt sich schmink tipps
kämpfe das recht auf eine andere sicht
von männlichkeit
menschen wie wir die sich outen und den
mut haben zu sich zu stehen die werden
gerne von anderen männern als weicheier
als unmännlich bezeichnet
dabei sind wie es doch die sich trauen
sich mit der regierung und der polizei
anzulegen
[Musik]
jessica ist ein star der underground
kultur ihre videos sind auch immer ein
statement sollen mut machen
[Musik]
für das sozialistische land verkörpert
jessica zu viel freiheit zu viel
individualismus das offizielle china
beschimpft menschen wie sie als sich
simon zu weiblich zu weich
sie ist eine provokation für chinas
führungseliten die männlich und älter
ist die kontrolliert alles im land die
politik die wirtschaft und immer mehr
auch das männlichkeitsbild hat
sie definieren wer zur sozialistischen
gemeinschaft dazu gehört und wer nicht
jeder hat ein recht auf sein eigenes
lebt das macht sinn männlichkeit neu zu
denken du kannst nicht verlangen dass
alle gleich sind
[Musik]
selten nur noch kann jessica so
ausgelassen ihre wandlungsfähigkeit
zelebrieren die szene trifft sich in
einem kleinen club in peking
sie leben am rande der gesellschaft
erfahren im alltag diskriminierung
verlieren ihre jobs
[Musik]
es gehört mut dazu eine drag-queen in
china zusammen
ich hoffe nur dass wir alle ein schönes
leben haben können und mutig genug sind
unser wahres ich zu leben
[Musik]
das ist
alles für die partei und das verfahren
waren
chinas verehrung für die kommunistische
partei wird von einem neuen
nationalismus getrieben zwischen
aufrichtigen patriotismus und gelernten
parolen wird hier dem ehemaligen
staatschef deng xiaoping gehuldigt
der erklärte in den 80er jahren die
stadt shenzen zu einer
sonderwirtschaftszone
damit begann chinas gigantischer
aufstieg zur wirtschaftswelt macht
er öffnete das land für die westliche
welt doch seit präsident hier regiert
stutzt der jede individuelle freiheit
seit einigen jahren erst müssen die
parteimitglieder wie in vergangenen
zeiten öffentlich gefolgschaft schwören
provinz gui so region südwest kia
digitalwirtschaft
abteilungen fortbildung
ausbildungslehrgang 2 alle schüler
angetrieben
dreimal verbeugen vor dem großartigen
kameraden denkt doping
[Musik]
casey war sieht sich die ersten entwürfe
am computer an die er gleich produzieren
will
[Musik]
der chinesische drache soll bald
symbolisch raketen spucken
tracy wong bewegt sich mit seinem
projekt auf einem schmalen grat zwischen
kunst und kriegerischer wirklichkeit
ich bin wirklich furchteinflößend das
waffensystem schaffen dass aus einem
mystischen wesen entsprechen
wenn die feindlichen friedhöfe angreifen
da schießen die raketen aus dem rachen
des drachen heraus und taiwan ist sicher
ein drache ist aus styropor seine kunst
ist verspielt doch die bedrohung ist
real
casey war weiß china wird taiwan zu
seiner provinz machen es steht viel auf
dem spiel
wir sollten uns nicht so sicher sein
dass die kommunistische partei chinas
niemals angreifen in einer
zivilgesellschaft hat jeder seine
aufgabe ich bin ein künstler ein
aktivist und ein bürger ich erfülle
meine pflicht mit hilfe meiner kunst
jeder einzelne wird gebraucht für die
freiheit und die demokratie
chinas angriff auf die freiheit zwang
ihn zur flucht
casey fonds schicksal ist eine mahnung
der chinesische traum vom persönlichen
aufstieg funktioniert bisher sie muss
sein volk satt machen darauf basiert die
loyalität
china folgt seinem präsidenten der
braucht sich nicht vor wählern zu
rechtfertigen ist auf lebenszeit
bestimmt
präsident biden regiert ein
zerstrittenes land ein drittel der
wähler hält ihn für nicht rechtmäßig
gewählt die vereinigten staaten haben
ihr inneres gleichgewicht verloren was
können die vereinigten staaten von
amerika chinas wachsende macht streben
entgegensetzen können sie ihre
politische vormachtstellung behaupten
wie können sie die wirtschaftliche
abhängigkeit von china reduzieren mehr
dazu in unserem zweiten teil von die
rivalen